but I think what you said a second ago
is having somebody who youth you see as
like a lighthouse in one hand and
somebody you see as somebody you can
help in some way of service yes in
another yeah because then that chain of
that chain of hands goes further down
and so then somebody's holding onto the
mud puddle step right that's just maybe
you're not in that part of the chain
that's just good way to look at it yeah
you know man I love it's not my most
it's not that I'm washing myself a
responsibility here right but that can
happen with the trick like if as long as
I'm looking to advance here like if I if
I don't look to make me the best
representation to take Fletcher that I
could be walking through the world today
yeah then anybody I would help is
diminished also it's like that it
becomes like that anyway you know your
highest good has to be to you yeah now
why is that so I can be useful to others
yeah that's it yeah you said the word
conjured a little bit ago and I think
more and more like that is more I take
care of myself the more I find that I
can be a conduit from some higher power
something to do things that help others
that make me then feel good yeah you
know and and I like you purposeful yes
right yeah a lot of it but like but you
rightful like like [ __ ] I you know is
that I remember the first time I dude
remember my name from like a lot of
people don't know how I could be helpful
this or that and I I was a new into LA
and I wouldn't be tearing up a little
bit I just yeah man I think so much
about how much being purposeful is just
it's becoming I think the thing it's it
listen like where the where this guy's
helpful to me I came back the next week
to the same place and it was like Tate
how are you doing he's got no [ __ ]
reason remember my name yeah but I'm mad
and it was the first time I go I
mattered like it felt and you can make
somebody feel like they matter if you
just [ __ ] get out of yourself enough
to remember their [ __ ] name tell the
next time you see them yeah and it's
like it becomes that thing and this
friend that you know there's a lot of
people in America it's weird because we
have more tense than ever I've never
seen I don't know if
tenseness became popular that people are
just really calling it camping instead
of homelessness and yeah but like right
on sunset like in downtown areas where
we never had it before I'm Beverly
Boulevard and last Cienega
there's tent set up last night and I was
like this is a [ __ ] this is crazy you
know and and with all that going on in
America and we got a president that's
saying we're winning like crate and and
people in the middle are like life's
always hard here it's always kind of
been sucky and it still is it's there's
no people with tents there cuz people
don't want to live in Indiana or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
yeah and and so they don't feel that but
let's like here on the fringes man we're
falling apart a little bit and and and
but the bottom line is regardless is
I've got a friend that's got what I
would call the disease of affluence and
and what happens is I used to work in
these nightclubs and I'd see all these
really rich kids and they grow up with
no consequences and and it's dangerous
man and it and it looks shitty to all of
us viewing it but really it with any
empathy it's worse for them and they
start to believe all kinds of lies and
things that when that veil is removed
from them that safety not holy it's
that's a dark dark area but with that I
have a friend that is like grew up in a
real advantageous environment yeah you
know and and it's like really delving
into spirituality and trying to figure
out herself and all that kind of stuff
and feels ashamed of it because doesn't
have the same concerns about having to
find a career this or that or whatever
that a lot of people do or and isn't
drawn to like having a baby and that
whatever all the things that people do
to avoid themselves right yeah no not my
purpose is my kid cuz I was too scared
to confront my own life and I don't know
how to live it so I [ __ ] out a kid and
I'm gonna show that mod of not do [ __ ]
too
yeah so she's making some real
courageous choices is my point
but like what is Oprah do what what does
Leonard Cohen do what does everybody do
as soon as they get papered up man they
try to find God they try to make sense
of it all with spirituality like
everybody looks towards those common
universal vibrations that echo through
all of our hearts and souls and connect
us all that's that we're trying to
curate that vibe of the universe
man that's what everybody tries to do
and so at whatever point you're trying
to do that that's that's the right end
game I think yeah and so when you say
it's turning more into this
consciousness I'm like I feel like that
that's that's the right place for us to
go yeah and there will be a schism there
will be a divide you know yeah yeah III
I mean I think we're on a lot of
elements however where I think there's a
lot of things where I didn't think it
for a little bit but now the more I find
myself being around that kind of stuff
the more I start to believe that that is
the truth which is interesting to you
speak it in I mean you can you speak the
truth into existence you know and I see
it I mean the more I ste put myself in
environments where I see people being
helpful to other people and stuff like
that the more I start to believe that
that's the answer that I never really
saw for some reason before you know when
all you really got to do is sit with
somebody that you really helped that
you've impacted and the feeling that
overwhelms me is that there's there's
never such a resounding feeling that I'm
in correct placement in the universe
right in the palm of the hand of God at
that very moment and I'm comforted in a
way that I never am when I'm deep into
service like that yeah there's nothing
that is like that there just isn't and
we look for it a lot of other places
that aren't the place yeah yeah man it's
the Easter egg hunt man chocolate
rabbits in our hearts dude you know it's
crazy as my sister can't even read but
what does it have to do with us right
now hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one